krump launches his reelection campaign
the media can barely hold themselves
back in fury and AOC steps on a
political landmine good news the
journalistic firefighters are there to
save her I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show I'll admit I'm already
tired from this news cycle I mean it's a
Wednesday and it feels like it should be
a Friday
maybe that's because yesterday I
discovered that my three-year-old son
knows the word dammit that happened that
happened during a swim lesson he just
looked up at his teacher and said dammit
and I looked down I said ha damn it well
well guess who all the actual news in
just a second but first what if buying a
house was like buying a timeshare you
show up with a herd of other people that
also wanted the free gift then you're in
a pressure cooker sales presentation for
90 minutes let's call it 3 hours you
don't have the opportunity to have your
real estate agent professionally
negotiate the price no inspector to
uncover hidden problems no loan officer
to explain every detail of the loan
terms interest rate fees payment
schedule total cost folks you wouldn't
buy a home this way but that's exactly
how the majority of time shares are sold
I know because I've been in a timeshare
presentation they're really good at what
they do but this is really not a great
way to buy anything remotely resembling
a timeshare it's pretty ridiculous and
if you're stuck in a timeshare if you
called the resort and they won't let you
out if you've tried selling it and you
can't call timeshare exit team right now
they will fight for you I trust them and
you can trust them as well I've known
them ever since I was doing a radio show
in Seattle I've seen them grow from a
very small business into a fairly large
business text been to 79 79 79 for a
free consultation that is my name Ben
ven in - 79 79 79 message and data rates
may apply you can trust the folks at
timeshare exit team to fight for you
when it comes to getting out of your
timeshare that's text Ben - 79 79 79 for
that free consultation with timeshare
exit team okay so the big news yesterday
was that the President of the United
States announced his reelection campaign
now it was a foregone conclusion he was
going to run for reelection of course
we've had very few presidents who have
decided not to run for re-election in
the history of the United States
obviously LBJ in 1968 decided he wasn't
going to run for reelection he'd already
been serving for five years by that
point then we've also seen folks like
James Polk not run for reelection Calvin
Coolidge but it's very rare for a
sitting president to decide not to run
for reelection Trump obviously was never
going to do that the man is a fighter by
Nature and so yesterday he finally made
the announcement he brought out all of
the Republican luminaries down to
Orlando Florida as I mentioned yesterday
on my radio show doing the rally in
Orlando is a sign that that Trump may
think that Florida is in play which
makes sense Florida is extraordinarily
closely divided if Trump loses Florida
he loses the election there's been a lot
of talk about Michigan and Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania but first things first
Trump does have to shore up Florida in
the polling he's running about even with
Joe Biden right now there's not a grave
indicator for Trump that Florida is lost
to him at this point if it were the
election as I say would basically be
over he drew 20,000 people last night
20,000 people a stadium full of people
and the crowd was raucous they were up I
mean people were into it president Trump
still has it I mean he has that star
power there is just no question and then
he brought forth his conquered
adversaries like the Romans bringing
back their enemies in Chains one of the
funny things about this rally was Trump
bringing forth all of the Senators who
had previously said that they would
never vote for him and that he was
really terrible to pay homage to him
everybody from Senator Lindsey Graham to
Marco Rubio being trotted out to endorse
the president for reelection because
obviously he's the president of the
United States the rally
got kicked off not with Trump but with
his vice president Mike Pence who will
be running with him all the speculation
about Pence being dumped from the ticket
in favor of somebody with a little bit
more star power that was never real he
was being at the Amway Center here was
Mike Pence talking about illegal
immigration and the fact that the
Democrats are stumping against illegal
immigration this is gonna continue to be
a hot-button issue for a huge number of
Americans particularly because Democrats
are incredibly radical and as we will
see their radical tendencies are leading
them into a real into a real cavern here
I mean it's it's not gonna go well for
them on immigration so long as they are
led by the radicals in their party like
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez we'll get to
that in just a little bit but here's
Mike Pence making the strong case in
favor of a a secure border we've
supported customs and border protection
we've stood by the courageous men and
women of ice and thanks to the
president's stand
Mexico has done more to secure our
border in the last 10 days then the
Democrats in Congress have done in the
last 10 years and obviously that is true
I mean the fact is that even as
Democrats complain about the conditions
on the border they have refused funding
for ice for Border Patrol they've
refused funding for the Department of
Homeland Security sufficient to allow
people to be kept on the border
okay so Pence leads this thing off the
crowd as I say is really raucous they
are really up now Trump speech was
effectively the same as every rally that
he's done for the last several years we
now live in an era of consistent
campaigning there is no point at which
the president is not campaigning for
reelection just as there is no point in
a 24/7 news cycle and which a congress
person is not campaigning for reelection
this was true of Barack Obama who never
actually disbanded his 2008 campaign he
just sort of morphed it and then he
morphed it back into a campaign around
2012 and then that campaign was
effectively handed over at least in
large part to Hillary Clinton in 2016
the era of the consistent campaign
thanks to media coverage is now and so
Donald Trump never stopped running but
he made his announcement official last
night he said he was officially running
and of course the crowd goes wild
we're going to keep on fighting for
every man and woman and child all across
this land with every ounce of heart and
mind and sweat and so we're going to
keep making America great again and then
we will indeed Keep America great
[Applause]
better than ever before and that is why
tonight I stand before you to officially
launch my campaign for a second term as
president of the United States
okay so they obviously in here the crowd
very enthusiastic and this is what
Republicans are counting on is that the
polls are under counting from voters or
that perhaps the polls aren't taking
account of the enthusiasm gap between
Democrats and Republicans certainly
President Trump's campaign manager was
saying exactly this Brad Pyrrha scale
his campaign manager said you know we
don't need to pay attention to the
polling the polling is dead now I think
this is a stay bridge too far I think
that the the odd circumstance by which
the polling on the state levels was off
dramatically in 2016 but the National
polling was correct I'm not sure that
you can continue to bet the data will
always be wrong but apparently this is
part of the campaign strategy here's
Brad power scale telling CBS News about
this country is too complex now to just
explain what you mean I just think the
country is too complex now just to call
a couple hundred people and ask him what
they think there are so many ways and
different people that are going to show
up the vote now the way turnout now
works and abilities that we have to turn
out voters it's not it the polling can't
understand that that's why it was so
wrong in 2016 it was 100% wrong nobody
had got it right okay well the truth is
that on the national level actually was
pretty good in 2018 it was also pretty
good so you know for the Trump campaign
to basically say polls don't matter I
understand this is all part of a
campaign tactic in order to make sure
that trumps base is not depressed that
they think that this election is is not
only winnable but winning for president
Trump even if the polls say otherwise
I'm not a fan of ignoring the data even
if the the long shot came in in 2016
that's basically what happened and Nate
Silver had it about a 70 to 30 shot
Hillary Clinton's gonna win a 70 to 30
shot is not a 100 to 0 shot I mean
sometimes 30 percent of the time the
underdog wins and that's what happened
in 2016 to kind of cast out all the data
I think is wrong but I understand that
it's part of a broader Trump campaign
strategy which is to get his own folks
to ignore whatever polling data comes
out in the somewhat justified belief
that the polls were mistaken in 2016 and
could easily be mistaken again
so President Trump's campaign is going
to be launched on two bases one is that
the Democrats are really really bad and
two is that his record is really good
those should be the two bases and then
there's this third basis upon which he
is launching the campaign that I think
is not going to be fruitful fruitful for
him and that is
that he is a victim I don't think that
presidents who proclaim that their
victims tend to win reelection very
often I think presidents who spend a lot
of time complaining that everybody is
mean to them look weak and that is not
something that the American people
sympathize with very strongly so when
President Trump is on the attack against
the Democrats he's in good shape when
he's talking about his stellar economic
record for example or his foreign policy
record which i think is overall very
good although I disagree with his North
Korean policy in particular I think is a
lot to brag about there but when he gets
into the what was me kind of routine
yeah that's red meat to the base but
it's not gonna win over anybody in the
middle who basically says you're
President of the United States stop
complaining dude so here's President
Trump with line number one the Democrats
are extraordinarily radical and they
want to destroy you and the country now
the media of course are going nuts over
this how could Trump say such a thing
Oh Barack Obama said things that were
very much like this in 2012
there's the implication from Democrats
consistently that Republicans wanted to
grind the poor under their heel that
Republicans are terrible for the country
that they want old people and sick
people to die I mean Bernie Sanders has
the sort of stuff on a routine basis I
mean right now that I'm like right now
the Democrats are claiming the Donald
Trump is setting up a holocaust on the
border we'll get to that in just a bit
but here's president from making the
case that Democrats want to destroy you
and the country his case against
Democratic radicalism will be a fruitful
line of attack for him the Democrats
don't care about Russia they only care
about their own political power but they
are really going after you that's what
it's all about
to deny you the future that you demanded
and the future that America deserves and
that now America is getting are driven
by hatred prejudice and rage they want
to destroy you and they want to destroy
our country as we know it not acceptable
it's not going to happen well this is
the core of his pitch the core of his
pitch was always that there are
motivated players inside the Democratic
Party who wants to see a fundamental sea
change in the nature of the country
and that those people are focused on
attacking the so called deplorable Zitz
why Hillary Clinton's attack on the
deplorable was a huge campaign error
there's been this burgeoning sense
inside a large part of the country that
Democrats sneer at a huge number of
Americans going all the way back to
Barack Obama suggesting the people in
the middle of the country were bitter
clingers who are focused on gods and gun
and xenophobia because they were poor
and stupid going all the way back to
then there is this feeling that there is
this huge culture gap and Trump has
taken advantage of that culture gap by
saying to a lot of folks well listen I
respect you but Democrats don't I take
you seriously but Democrats don't when
you tell me that you have problems in
your life I take that seriously
Democrats claim that you are
beneficiaries of white privilege
Democratic radicalism is Trump's best
friend here it is Trump's best friend
and Trump continues along those lines he
also suggests what the Democrats are
socialists and they're openly
proclaiming they're socialists and this
isn't a socialist country more than 120
Democrats in Congress have also signed
up to support crazy Bernie Sanders
socialist government takeover of health
care
they want to end Medicare as we know it
and terminate the private health
insurance of 180 million Americans who
love their health insurance America will
never be a socialist country again
attacks on Democrats are going to be a
fruitful line of attack because
Democrats don't know what to do with it
many of them want to double down on this
and then some like Joe Biden don't know
whether to double down or whether to run
away from it we'll get to Biden in just
a second who's experiencing another
campaign gaffe again I think his
campaign is much weaker than advertised
we'll get some more of that in a second
first I know a lot of folks people in my
generation who have an enormous amount
of student debt that is not uncommon at
all and can saddle you it can really
make your life miserable Millennials
have three times as much student debt as
their parents which is a problem but you
can get your student loans right by
refinancing those loans with sofa sofa
is the leading student loan refinance er
in the United States they've refinanced
hundreds of thousands of student loans
it's fast it's easy it's all online you
can check your rate in two minutes and
lock in a fix low rate this matters
because you may be 10 years out of
school and still with half a million
dollars in debt and now you can't buy a
house you may need to refinance that
debt refinance with sofa because it
could save you money by lowering your
interest rate or choosing one of sofas
flexible terms you could end up saving
thousands of dollars when you refinance
your student loans with sofa you also
get access to sofa membership giving you
access to exclusive benefits to help you
get ahead with your money life and
career lock-in that fixed low rate today
at sofa comm slash Ben that's SOF i.com
slash Ben so if I London corp CFL member
six zero five four six one two go check
them out right now at sofa comm slash
Ben and go check out what kind of low
rates can get on refinancing that
student loan that's sof Icom slash Ben
okay so president Trump launched his
first line of attack Democrats are gonna
be terrible for the country and they
have a different vision fruitful line of
attack his second line of attack is I've
accomplished a lot of things and he
talked about the economy a little he
talked about that but that's not really
where Trump's heart lies he's not
talking about all of his accomplishments
his wall still his heart still lies in
the applause lines one of the problems
for President Trump is a campaigner is
that President Trump really enjoys being
in front of crowds that is great as a
performer and basically that's
Trump is right Trump is a performer if
you've ever been to one of his rallies
or seen one of his events he's a
stand-up comedian he's a stand-up
comedian who stands in front of large
crowds and tells jokes and delivers
applause lines and so he goes back to
sort of the tried and true old standards
here
here's a mash-up of his various heads
many times I said we would drain the
swamp and that's exactly what we're
doing right now we're draining the swamp
just in case Hillary Clinton lost
remember the insurance policy
and we are building the wall we're gonna
have over 400 miles of wall built by the
end of next year it's moving rapidly
attempting lock her up there was a point
during this rally where the crowd
started chanting CNN sucks at which
point CNN actually cut away who's made
say that the media are not biased in any
way they they're not just trying to
preserve themselves in any way CNN I
mean there's footage of it
president Trump starts talking the crowd
starts chanting CNN sucks and so CNN in
retaliation cuts away from the
president's reelect rally the amount of
press we have tonight reminds me of the
Academy Awards before it went political
and their ratings went down the tubes
this was our chance all right we've been
watching the president kick off his
re-election bid he's been on stage for
about six minutes within two minutes he
did talk about the economy about within
four minutes it was attacks on the
media's and that's unacceptable
according to CNN we'll get to the media
in just one second their reaction to all
of this now as I say Trump's third line
of attack so it's accomplishments
Democrats suck and his third line of
attack which is I'm a victim and this is
the one I don't think is going to be
particularly fruitful for him
Republicans who claim that they are the
victims generally don't do well and it
makes you unpopular Hillary Clinton made
herself deeply unpopular by suggesting
that she was a target of a vast
right-wing conspiracy people who tend to
claim victimhood at the highest level of
politics they don't tend to do great
here as president Trump yesterday
suggesting that while Hillary Clinton's
deleted emails were not a big deal if he
deleted a love note to Melania Trump he
would be fair game can you imagine if I
got a subpoena
they give this if I got a subpoena for
emails if I deleted one email like a
love note to Milania it's the electric
chair for Trump okay then it's funny
it's also not going to be particularly
fruitful so the president needs to stick
to the first two messages if he hopes to
win reelection message number one
Democrats are gonna take us in the wrong
direction number two I've you may not
like me personally but I've taken you in
the right direction
your pocketbook looks good we look
better on foreign policy that is gonna
be his real eye patch okay so the media
reacts to all of this with astonishment
astonishment to Trump actually raised in
the first day of his re-election
according to the RNC he raked in nearly
25 million dollars in campaign
contributions according to the
chairwoman of the RNC Rhonda McDaniel
wrote on Twitter that he had raised
twenty four point eight million dollars
in less than 24 hours
by contrast Joe Biden since the launch
of his campaign has raised a total of 19
point eight million dollars so Trump
raised more than one day than Biden has
in the course of his campaign now
obviously that is not a complete apples
to apples comparison the fact is that
Trump is the nominee on the Republican
side or will be the nominee on the
Republican side whereas there's a lot of
Democratic money that is split among
various contenders probably there's been
some 50 to 60 million dollars already
split amongst the various Democratic
contenders at this point still that is a
massive showing in the first day
according to Politico if it represents a
first day fundraising total for the
campaign that would nearly quadruple the
six point three million dollars that
former VP Joe Biden raked in within his
initial 24 hours as an announced 2020
White House contender Chris Cuomo was
astonished by the size of the crowd at
Trump's rally 20,000 people showing up
the media still don't understand that
there are a lot of people who kind of
like President Trump that he infected
wins 63 million votes in the last
election cycle and that he is very
popular with the bases 90% approval
rating among the base here's Chris Cuomo
can't believe it so based on the
capacity of the Arena in Orlando what we
see from the seating there's probably
20,000 people at this rally for the
president tonight and that is bigger
than Democrats are getting so far to be
sure is the size of the RAL
suggestive of the 60 million plus votes
needed to win the next presidential
election now maybe not but it has to
mean something that his Democrats are
playing these little clubs in Iowa and
New Hampshire Donald Trump is playing
arenas okay well obviously that is true
CBS news was also reporting on the size
of the crowd they reported that people
were coming all across America to watch
Trump's reelect kick off there was a
day-long festival there outside the
arena where supporters of the president
were were gathered and there were
reports as about this time last night
that there were already a handful of
people who had been waiting for hours to
get a seat in the venue a sign perhaps
of the sustained support for the
president there in Central Florida okay
so the media are very nervous about
President Trump and their nervousness is
coming out in the most radical possible
way they are they're reverting to the
Donald Trump is Hitler line so Don Lemon
you know along with Chris Cuomo so two
blocks of wood on TV Don Lemon suggests
that President Trump is just like Hitler
in in the sense that Hitler also had
Jewish grandchildren moved the US
Embassy to Jerusalem and was generally
Philo Semitic in that way exactly like
Hitler here's Don Lemon making this
idiotic case as an objective news anchor
on see he's so objective he and Chris
Cuomo I mean the level of objectivity is
stunning think about the despicable
people we've had in history okay I'm
going to use an extreme example think
about Hitler think about any of those
people would you say that that person is
allowed or let's put it this way if you
could look back on in history would you
say well I'm so glad that that person
was allowed a platform so that they
could spread their hate and propaganda
in lies or would you say it probably
wasn't the right thing to do to spread
that because you knew in the moment that
that was a bad person and they were
doing bad things not only were they
hurting people they were killing people
okay he was specifically talking about
whether in networks should be airing the
speeches of the President of the United
States he just compared to Hitler man
the journalism in at CNN I can't imagine
why people at Trump rallies shout CNN
sucks just can't imagine it why would
they do such a thing
with Joe
like that just getting the journalism
everywhere I mean it's just it's
incredible it's it's an incredible
showing of objectivity and journalistic
firefighting by our media establishment
and listen they're just doing their jobs
guys I mean come on they're just sitting
there
fact-checking President Trump in real
time they're just there ensuring that
President Trump doesn't descend doesn't
dissimulate he doesn't he hasn't lied he
doesn't dissemble to the American people
hey that's that's what they have to make
sure of they just they will put little
KY ron's at the bottom of his speeches
saying that what he's saying is not true
they are making sure that the
fact-checking is tuned up to 11 they're
dispassionate arbiters of the truth who
are standing up for the American people
that's what Jim Acosta says and I
believe Jim Acosta because Jim Acosta is
a model citizen when it comes to
journalism now I know I know this is all
incredibly stupid
I mean members of the media overall
despise President Trump they despise
Republicans they despise conservatives
it oozes from their every pore and if
you don't believe me all you have to do
is watch their coverage for about 24
hours
that's it all you have to do is watch
their coverage for a grand total of
approximately 24 hours and contrast
their coverage of say a Democrat who
says things that are untrue and stupid
on a routine basis with their coverage
of President Trump a president Trump
says a lot of things that are untrue and
ridiculous and I call him out on those
things when Democrats do it the media
treat it as though Democrats are just
good hearted people trying hard to do
the right thing while President Trump is
a Hitlerian liar case in point
AOC we'll get to her in just one second
first not a lot of people who are trying
to use your data and make money off of
it basically all the social media
companies do is take our data and then
make money off of it well why shouldn't
you control your data and make money off
of it big token is a new app it lets you
share data about yourself your interest
in your habits and then you get paid for
it right now you share an enormous
amounts of information with tech
companies they make money off of it so
should you this is where big token comes
in here's how it works first you
download the app and you sign up for a
free big token account next you complete
actions to earn points actions include
answering surveys checking into
locations connecting your social
accounts and more then you can redeem
your points for awards like cash and
gift cards or don't
your earnings to charity you choose what
data is shared with big token and then
you get paid for it
the surveys in the app will ask general
questions about your demographics and
lifestyle and specific follow-up
questions based on what you answered you
can also get more points for referring
friends and family your data is always
secured in big token so if you want to
start earning money for your data go to
the App Store or Google Play
search for big token that's b.i.g tok
and that is one more download the app
and sign up right now make sure to use
my referral code shapiro again search
big token in the App Store Google Play
download the app use my referral code
Shapiro to sign up claim your data and
get paid for it as opposed to letting
other people make money off your data
okay so speaking of the media is insane
bias all you have to do to detect the
media is insane bias is follow how they
treat the estimable aoc intellectual
heavyweight woman with an IQ I would say
easily of 95 I mean she is she is just
incredibly bright incredibly facile
really in control of her of her
knowledge so yesterday we commented on
this briefly because it didn't seem like
it required for their comment but
apparently according to the media it
does aoc was doing an Instagram in which
she compared detention of illegal
immigrants at detention centers where
they are fed and where they are housed
and where they are kept pending an
asylum trial she compared that to
concentration camps and specifically she
compared it to Nazi concentration camps
now I know everybody is ignoring the
actual text of what she said everybody's
ignoring what she said she drops the
reference never again at the end of this
clip when you say never again you are
specifically making a reference to the
Holocaust but the media took various
lines of attack to defend aoc first they
claimed she wasn't talking about the
Holocaust then she could they claimed
well there are other concentration camps
that aren't the Holocaust that she is
talking about then they claimed well
maybe it kind of is like the Holocaust
after all there they're basically trying
everything they could do to spin aoc out
of her own stupidity I'm very much
looking forward to seeing how far a OC
can push this honestly I'm really would
love to see a OC come out tomorrow and
suggest that the earth is flat and
watches the media explain that not only
is she correct that it's Donald Trump's
fault that's that's where we are going
here so here's a Oasys original comment
the United States is running
concentration camps on our southern
border and that is exactly what they are
they are concentration camps and if that
doesn't bother you I don't I like we can
have okay whatever I'm gonna talk to the
people that are concerned enough with
humanity to say that we should not that
never again means something
okay she drops in never again reference
because she's obviously talking about
the Holocaust like whatever um yeah like
what I'm so historically knowledgeable
like um but I didn't what I'm yeah sure
sure okay so then she tweets this out
okay just to be clear she tweeted this
out also she tweeted this administration
has established concentration camps on
the southern border of the United States
for immigrants where they are being
brutalized with dehumanizing conditions
and dying hey number one the deaths that
are happening at the border are not due
to Border Patrol Border Patrol's being
delivered people who are very often in
seriously sick conditions and then they
are doing their best to care for those
people despite underfunding caused by
Democrats who will not sign a check for
additional beds and better conditions
because what Democrats want to do is
force bad headlines so that that
Republicans and and law enforcement will
release people into the interior of the
United States where they disappear and
don't show up again that is the goal
it's absolutely cynical and disgusting
AOC then tweets out and for the
shrinking Republicans who like unlike la
whatever like um who don't know the
difference concentration camps are not
the same as death camps Oh tell me tell
me AOC tell me all about it
drop some historical knowledge on me AOC
about concentration camps and the
Holocaust
she says concentration camps are
considered by experts as the mass
detention of civilians without trial no
that is not what concentration camps are
considered by experts and when you put
it in scare quotes you might want to
quote the expert you're talking about so
we can dispute this if all the
concentration camps were or detention of
civilians without trial you know what we
would call those jails
that's what jails are when you arrest
somebody and you don't try them and you
hold them in jail pending the trial are
those concentration camps
I assume that maybe she would say yes
because she's a crazy person she also
says that's exactly
what this administration is doing okay
so first you'll see the media tried to
claim that she didn't mean what she said
obviously she's not obvious how could
you guys say that she's talking about
the Holocaust I mean sure she used never
again but she's not talking about that
when she says concentration camps she
means camps where people concentrate
like where they sit there and stare at
things or they drink juice made from
concentrate probably that's what she's
talking about now anyone who watches
this knows precisely what she is talking
about but that is no good apparently
according to brian Stelter at CNN
journalistic ombudsman ocn he claims
that the MSNBC viewers who watched this
knew she wasn't talking about the
holocaust weird because half the media
are claiming that she was and that she's
right and the other half are claiming
that she wasn't so which is it guys so
hilariously enough Yad Vashem the
Holocaust Memorial Museum had to sound
off on this and they tweeted out a OC
concentration camps assured a slave
labor supply to help in the Nazi war
effort even as the brutality of life
inside the camps helped assure the
ultimate goal of extermination through
labor learn about concentration camps
hashtag Holocaust hashtag history when
you're getting sub tweeted not sub
tweeted actually tweeted by Yad Vashem
about the history of the Holocaust not
great and then the acting ice director
comes out he says this is absurd because
of course this is absurd the
congresswoman has accused this agency
and particularly this department of
housing people for housing migrants in
which she calls concentration camps do
you think that's an inappropriate
comparison for the congresswoman to make
it's completely inappropriate
it's reckless it's irresponsible its
misinformed and it's flat-out wrong and
of course that is 100% truth Liz Cheney
jumped in as well one of the high
ranking House members for the Republican
Party she jumped in she said please EOC
do us all a favor and spend just a few
minutes learning some actual history six
million Jews were exterminated in the
Holocaust you to mean their memory and
disgrace yourself with comments like
this number one I would like to point
out here that the exact same people who
are defending the comparison between
detention camps at the southern border
detention centers at the southern border
and concentration camps from the
Holocaust side with Iran and Camus and
want a boycott the State of Israel so
when we're talking about the actual
extermination of Jews they're like oh
well whatever
and when it comes to you know people
being temporarily held
they're trying to get into the country
illegally then I say oh that's just like
the Holocaust guys talk about
trivializing the Holocaust that would be
it and it's amazing the lengths to which
people will go to spin this thing so
somebody pointed out yesterday you know
one of the differences between the
detention centers at the border and the
Holocaust and concentration camps
generally is that usually concentration
camps don't involve people trying to get
into the country the Jews were not
fleeing to get into Germany and then the
Germans were like I'll look at all these
illegal immigrants we better jail them
pending trial mostly the Jews were
trying to get out because they were
being slaughtered and exterminated well
my favorite part of this is that a Oh C
then comes up with another line of
attack it's so funny she comes up with
these various lines of attack and
Democrats have to shift on the move to
defend her because they're so stupid I
mean what she says is so dumb so she
then tweet a Liz Cheney says you know
when you're talking about concentration
camps lots of Jews got exterminated
here's a OCS no no we need we need the
extermination me the in nineteen is what
we need here a OC then tweets out she
tweets out that it is just very very bad
that Liz Cheney used the term
extermination she says maybe you should
learn history using Nazi terms like
extermination is really bad you can't do
that
um Yad Vashem just used the term
extermination because that's part of
history
here is here's a OC responding to Liz
Cheney she used the term extermination
which is co-opting the language
of that you know that term implies the
people who died in the Holocaust it
doubles down on the rhetoric that
justified it and so I think it's I mean
I think she's one of these doer homework
um well that's a thing a human being
said it is I will say she can perform
incredible feats aoc but it is it is
incredible to me that a human being can
shove her head so far up her ass that it
comes out her head again and it she
apparently does it everyday and then the
media cheer her on like seals it's
amazing it's amazing stuff get some more
of this in just one second you wonder
why folks don't trust the media maybe
it's because they are fact-checking
Hitler Trump in real time but AO C is
the beloved of the media as you will see
CNN which declared Trump Hitler also
says that aoc who is trivializing the
Holocaust which is what she is doing
here because she's an ignorant
that that is actually not trivialize
she's a hero we'll get to that in just a
second first we're never going to agree
on everything but we can all agree that
we could use more sleep getting a great
night's sleep it's easier and more
affordable than you think now you may
think that you need a new mattress or
sleeping pills or some other fancy
schmancy thing instead what you really
need is to change the sheets that's why
you should check out bowl and branch
everything bowl and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton
it means they start out super soft and
they get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store
bolon brand sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks everyone who tries Boleyn
brand sheets loves them shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund but you're not gonna want to send
them back there's no risk no reason not
to give them a try my wife and I have
bull and branch eats they are
spectacular they're so good in fact that
I can't even sleep on anything it's not
pulling branch at this point they
basically ruined other sheets for me to
get you started right now my listeners
get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets at bull and branch calm promo
code Ben go to bowl and branch calm
today for 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets
that's bol and branch calm promo code
Ben bull and branch calm promo code Ben
okay
in just a second we'll get to more on
AOC and her absolute ignorance in the
media's willing eager defense of her ok
in in the
of some famous Twitter people guys she's
not gonna date you okay but we'll get to
that in just one second first let me
remind you we are taking our backstage
live show on the road for a very special
one-night only event August 21st at the
terrorist theater in Long Beach
California that is correct I the
god-king Jeremy boring Andrew Clavin
Michael Mills for some reason even more
important than Noel's The Daily wire
merchandise table will be there alive I
mean the table won't be alive it'll be
dead but we will be there alive except
for Noel's hopefully we'll talk politics
pop culture and my favorite part answer
your questions live from the audience
which is always the best part plus
people will be pontifical they'll smoke
cigars and be genuine asses tickets go
on sale to the public this Friday but
today through Thursday only daily where
subscribers yet exclusive presale
tickets s which is one of the reasons
you should subscribe become a subscriber
get your tickets today come join us for
a fantastic event or at least a mediocre
events I'm forced to be at so come join
us become a subscriber and at least hang
out with me guys I mean if I have to be
there at least give me some company
other than these guys who I see every
day in seriously also you should
subscribe because there's all sorts of
goodies to ours additionally every
afternoon we have all sorts of goodies
behind the paywall for 99 bucks a year
you get this the very greatest in
beverage vessels the leftist tiers hut
or cold tumbler which is just like a
concentration camp according to AOC
because it's a tumbler that holds things
so you should probably go check that out
as well $99 a year you get all of those
glories also you're helping us out the
fact is that the militant left is
interested in shutting down all debate
ng platforming everyone you help us
protect against that by becoming part of
the team please join us over at daily
wire calm
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so it wasn't just yad vashem
which sounded off and told a OC that she
is wrong it was also the JCR sea of new
york which is the canoe central
coordinating and resource body for sixty
plus jewish organizations in the New
York metro area they wrote a letter to
her yesterday saying we are deeply
disturbed by the language used in your
recent Instagram live video which seeks
to equate the detention centers on
America's southern border with Nazi era
concentration camps the terms
concentration camp and never again are
synonymous with and evocative of the
atrocities committed by Adolf Hitler's
Nazi Germany in which six million
European Jews were systematically denied
civil and human rights due to their race
and ultimately murder in the
state-sponsored genocide as concerned as
we are about the conditions experienced
by migrants seeking asylum in the United
States including family separation
unusable facilities and lack of food
water and medical resources the
regretable use of Holocaust terminology
to describe these contemporary concerns
diminishes the evil intent of the Nazis
to eradicate the Jewish people we urge
you to refrain from using terminology
evocative of the Holocaust to voice
concerns about contemporary political
issues this is by the way a nonpartisan
Jewish group that includes a bunch a
bunch of liberals in it okay and that
didn't stop the media the media came out
in full-scale defense of the idiocy of
aoc Kevin Cruz Twitter's favorite
historian over Princeton he started
tweeting out in her defense he says we
associate the Holocaust with death camps
like Auschwitz but those didn't come out
of nowhere concentration camps like
Dachau had been around since 1933
setting the principle that ash whit's
then built upon so to prevent another
ostrich protest another death oh okay so
now Cruz is comparing detention centers
at the border for illegal immigrants
trying to enter the country pending
trial to Dachau which was I mean again
the level of historical ignorance from
the supposed historian is astonishing
Dachau was supposedly a home for German
citizens who were dissenters it was made
apolitical it was made a political
detention center for political enemies
of the Nazi regime as early as 1933 to
compare that to what happened at the
border is insane
it's insane hey but this is what but
he's a don't worry he's a historian guys
Chris Hayes Chris Hayes of MSNBC tweets
out if you spend a few minutes learning
some actual history you will
the concentration camps are different
from death camps and have a history that
both predates and extends far past the
Nazis which is of course why AOC used
the term never again which is a
holocaust specific term I'm sure that
I'm sure she was talking about the
bowler war really she's an expert on the
Transvaal she's an expert AOC is on the
internecine warfare between the British
Empire and the attempted South African
Republic and all it goes back to the
bowler war guys that's really Chris
Hayes is right on it guys that's what
she's talking about that's what she's
table and then Jerry Nadler gets
involved the democratic New York
Congress person he says one of the
lessons from the Holocaust is never
again not only to mass murder but also
to the dehumanization of people
violations of basic rights and assaults
on our common morality we failed to
learn that lesson when we don't call out
such an humanity right in front of us so
I feel like Nadler here is losing the
thread so you got Kevin Cruz and Chris
Hayes making the case she wasn't talking
about the Holocaust and wasn't talking
about Nazi concentration camps and then
Nadler is saying no no she was talking
about it but it is like the Holocaust
you gonna have to pick a lane guys was
she was she misappropriating the
Holocaust because she's adult or was she
exactly correct and Trump is actually
incipient Hitler pick one little Chris
Cuomo picked aside he says Trump is
incipient Hitler this is an amazing so
Chris Cuomo again brilliant objective
news anchor yesterday on CNN he claims
the concentration camp says no Nazi
connotations I'll be honest I did not
see that coming but he says
concentration camps have no Nazi
connotations at all mm-hmm but you know
what does have a Nazi connotation
America first so Donald Trump saying
America first is just like the Nazis a
concentration camps is not a reference
to the Nazis so he's calling Trump a
Nazi while saying that aoc was not
calling Trump a Nazi because
concentration camps have nothing to do
with the Nazis okay makes sense if
you're crazy
there's Chris Cuomo on CNN I say
concentration camps because that's how
they are defined internationally that's
what these are I am NOT equating with
stigma of the Nazis and the Jews leave
that part aside we all know what the
connotation of concentration camps is if
we went out on the street and asked 100
people 99 of them would tell us I would
give us an explanation or a definition
that relates to Nazism she used the
phrase never again which we know is
specifically linked to the Holocaust to
the Shoah and that is disgraceful
AOC should apologize at the least and
probably resign one point of pushback
before I get to you Angela you did not
have similar problems with the phrase
America first which is equally stained
or the word nationalist now which is
easy for a state no holy crap the word
nationalism is equally stained with
Nazism truly nationalism is equally
state do you know historically ignorant
you have to be to believe that seriously
nationalism or the phrase America first
is equally stay with Nazism is
concentration camps are media guys I
understand that you're getting those
massage oils ready I understand that you
you desperately want to to carry the
drool Cup for aoc but my god you wonder
why your credibility is in the toilet
maybe it's because you will Bend
yourself into pretzels that make the
pretzel companies jealous in order to
achieve the justification for aoc
stupidity I just honestly I'm looking
forward to seeing what other stupid crap
a OC can say that you guys will defend
because apparently you guys will all the
way down this rabbit hole every inch of
the way it is unbelievable
unbelievable you keep doing this is it
great it is by the way I will note also
that AOC doubled down today
she changed her metaphor now it's no
longer Nazi concentration camps now it's
just like Japanese internment so now
we're gonna get the Twitter historians
today explaining that holding people who
are illegally crossing the border
pending a trial and pending an asylum
what that may let them become citizens
or that may deport them to their home
countries is just like interning
Japanese American citizens of the United
States without trial for years on end
during World War two
which by the way was done by Bernie
Sanders his hero FDR it's exactly the
same thing okay meanwhile Democrats are
trying to counter all of this with with
Joe Biden
so it's chaos on that side of the aisle
Donald Trump is not a popular man hey
just by poll data Donald Trump is not
popular but I'll tell you it's not going
to help you the media chasing aoc like a
desperate
and craving attention on the one hand
and Joe Biden on the other hand so Joe
Biden
has himself in trouble again today
because it is a day ending and why he
did a campaign riff yesterday apparently
when he was in the Senate he talked
about when he was in the Senate he said
that he would occasionally cut deals
with segregationists he said I was in a
caucus with James O Eastland and then he
launched into a nostalgic riff about the
good old days when senators could argue
with each other but still compromise and
this is driving people up a wall because
what he said is yeah there are some bad
people but we still came to compromises
and that's what the Senate is all about
you're not allowed to say these things
you're not allowed to say them and
people are rightly or wrongly going
after Biden on this basis people
pointing out that the folks that he is
talking about cutting deals with or some
of the worst segregationists in American
history yeah.he Biden is just going to
keep stepping in it and stepping in it
and set because he doesn't know where
the lines are because the lines keep
moving on him it is pretty amazing
Jonathan Chait
over at New York Magazine has a long
piece about this he says at first blush
Biden's segregationist riff is
disturbing when you poke below the
surface it gets even more disturbing it
suggests he has not grasped any of the
tectonic changes in American politics
and that he's equipped neither for the
campaign nor the presidency as American
politics has grown more polarized
because the unusual and precarious
conditions of the 20th century have
disappeared politics in the 19th century
was deeply polarized around linked
issues of race and big government but
after reconstruction was crushed the
Republican Party abandoned its
commitment to African American equality
and activist government while the
Democratic Party eventually adopted
those identities weird because the
Democrats after reconstruction were
still the dominant party in the south so
that's not historically true but he
talks about how basically Mitch
McConnell and the Republicans are the
root of all evil and represent the
segregationist today and Joe Biden is
still trying to make deals with them and
this is the big part of the problem
so Biden is not going to be let off the
hook his sort of charming old codger
stuff is not going to be of much use to
him in this whole fight he's going to be
attacked mercilessly by the other
Democrats and by the media who by the
way are beginning to notice it's amazing
how conveniently the note
the media notice things it's pretty
incredible so the media only noticed
that Joe Biden happens to be a habitual
liar occasionally so when he's running
for president like 1988 and then not for
eight years when he was vice president
but now again they're beginning to
notice that Joe Biden makes things up
prevaricate an enormous amount and that
he says dumb things repeatedly by the
way here's what Biden said he said I was
in a caucus with James O Eastland he
never called me boy he always called me
son he said that that there was another
senator named Talmadge who was a
segregationist
that would be Herman Talmadge of Georgia
he said Talmadge was one of the meanest
guys I ever knew you go down a list of
all the guys well guess what at least
there was some civility we got things
done we didn't agree on much of anything
we got things done we got it finished
but today you look at the other side and
you're the enemy not the opposition the
enemy we don't talk to each other
anymore hey and this apparently is Joe
Biden being too easy on segregationist
despite the fact that he said he didn't
agree with segregationist but that in
the Senate you make deals this is not
good for the Democratic Party and the
New York Times comes after him on that
basis we are also going to see the New
York Times coming after him on the basis
of the fact that he tells stories that
are not true Joe Biden makes up fish
stories routinely it's pretty amazing
actually here is one of the fish stories
that he just that he told in 1989 for
example Biden wrote about this in in
1989 he says that he moved into the
office of an old senator named Stennis
who is a segregationist and here's
Biden's story he walked in and then
Stennis said you see this table Joe this
table was the flagship of the
Confederacy from 1954 to 1968 we sat
here most of us from the deep south the
old Confederacy and we planned the
demise of the civil rights movement and
we lost and Joe now it's time that this
table go from the possession of a man
who was against civil rights to a man
who was for civil rights the civil
rights movement did more to free the
white men than the black men Stennis
said according to Biden he could see me
looking at him confused any pounds in on
his chest and said it freed my soul does
anyone actually believe that this
happened okay none this never happened
and this is he tells these kind of
stories all the time those Joe Biden
here's another story that Joe Biden
tells because he is a habitual liar this
is this is the funny
people our job ID and that's an honest
man Joe Biden in a debate in an open
debate for the vice presidency in 2012
suggested that NATO had kicked Hezbollah
out of Lebanon Hezbollah never left
Lebanon yeah Paul Ryan didn't know
enough to call him on it but I remember
sitting there watching the debate going
that's not even close to true here's my
favorite Joe Biden story this is brought
to you by the way courtesy of Alex
Griswold who writes over at the at the
Washington Examiner I believe and it's
it's pretty sorry the Washington free
beacon here is a story that Joe Biden
told recently he said my dad was on his
way to a job in the morning and this if
you know anything about my city of
Wilmington there's a place called Rodney
square and the buildings surrounding
Rodney Square were the de pon company
the Hercules Corporation which was big
then the I CI Americas and so there were
a lot of plain grey suits and an awful
lot of at 8:00 a.m. in the morning an
awful lot of men and women hustling off
to work and we were stopped at the light
two men on the right very well-dressed
men obviously businesspeople who working
for either Hercules or DuPont turned and
embraced one another and kissed each
other and they went their separate ways
I'll never forget I turned and looked at
my dad just looked at him and I'll never
forget what he said he said Joey they
love each other it's simple they love
each other it's simple that's what this
has been about all from the beginning so
Biden was 17 in 1959 so according to Joe
Biden in 1959 he was driving through
downtown Wilmington and saw two male
businessmen kissing each other in the
business district in full view of
everyone in a state where homosexuality
was illegal and his Irish Catholic dad
media writes about this who's born in
1917 saw the two men kissing and turned
to his son and said Joey they love each
other if you believe this story this is
because you are dumb okay Joe Biden
tells these sorts of stories all the
time he's gonna fall apart he's gonna
blow up on the launch pad but not
because he's dishonest he's been
dishonest for a long time he's gonna
blow up on the launch pad because the
media are gonna start treating him the
way they treat Trump there's only two
types of treatment from the media
there's the aoc treatment and there's
the Trump treatment he's gonna receive
the Trump treatment the media have
decided they're not interested in a Joe
Biden presidency and so they're going to
tear him down up until the point he
becomes the nominee if he survives that
long at which point he will get the aoc
treatment that's the way this is going
to go
and then people wonder why we don't
trust the media okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like there is a
movie that is actually quite good on
Netflix you sort of have to have the
ending explained it to you so I won't
spoil it for you but the the movie is
called I am mother I am a sucker for
sci-fi I really like sci-fi and the
basic premise of the movie is that there
is a robot in the future that is raising
a baby in a condition in which all of
humanity has died outs is in a bunker
and then a human knocks on the door
basically and what happens next the
whole thing is obviously supposed to be
metaphorical and the ending is not
properly spelled out you actually have
to read about what the ending was about
to get with you Annie wasn't there like
oh that makes sense
but here's a little bit of the preview
it is well acted it is Rose Byrne who
does the voice of the robot is terrific
here's a here's a little bit of the
preview there used to be then why did
you only make one mothers need time to
learn
this facility was designed to give
humanity a second chance one that began
with you daughter
[Music]
the path will not be easy
world outside is lifeless
but I need you into the woman that you
are so that we could do this together
okay so unintentionally this is one of
the most pro-life movies ever
unintentionally like completely
unintentionally they're a bunch of
fetuses and embryos that are that are in
early stage development and there is an
ending sequence shows the robot taking a
in embryo and then putting it in an
artificial womb and it growing there is
no way to look at that and not say that
this is a human life there's no way to
do that they didn't mean to do this I
think when they made the movie because
no one in Hollywood it ever mean to do
this but there's a whole debate over I
mean the the girl basically at one point
turns to the other human and says I need
to go save my brothers and sisters can't
have been born yet I mean from the
images they're probably 10 weeks old
maybe 9 weeks old unintentionally it's a
supremely pro-life movie if they found
out about this they probably pull the
movie it is that pro-life but go check
it out I am mother and then go read up
on the ending because the ending does
make a lot of sense but only when it's
explained to you which means they should
have written it a little differently you
know you shouldn't have to have endings
explained to you but in any case go
check it out it's really good and
honestly well done Netflix okay time for
some things that I hate so a couple of
things that I hate today so we begin
with slavery reparations so the House
Democrats are going to hold another one
of these these show peace routines where
they bring in Tana he's he coats and
Danny Glover to talk about slavery
reparations now Tana he codes has
written this essay about slavery
reparations I've gone through it on the
show before it is wildly overpraised
basically it just talks about how much
black people have suffered thanks to
slavery
100% true all of that is true also he's
provided no workable framework for
reparations who should receive who
should give what should the cutoff be
how exactly should all of this work how
much do people who are not involved in
slavery oh people who are also not
slaves and haven't had ancestors who
were slaves for about a hundred fifty
years right what how does this work
House Democrats are gonna hold the
hearing on this and it will basically be
anybody who opposes slavery reparations
is racist how do we know this because
Mitch McConnell was asked about
reparations here's what the Senate
majority leader had to say yeah I don't
think reparations for something that
happened 150 years ago for whom
currently living or responsible is a
good idea we've you know tried to deal
with our original sin of slavery by
fighting a civil war about passing
landmark civil rights legislation we've
elected an african-american president
first of all would be pretty hard to
figure out who to compensate we've had
waves of immigrants as well who've come
to the country and experienced dramatic
discrimination of one kind or another so
no I don't think reparations are a good
idea okay so he says that that's a
reasonable point of view that is a very
reasonable point of view here's how Don
Lemon characterizes it on CNN maybe you
should give back some of your wealth
maybe you should give back here at
grandfathers college degree maybe should
get back your great-great grandfather's
land that you were given and you know on
and on and on
yeah people weren't there but people
reap the benefits from it and that is
the whole point of the matter and social
programs are not reparations
he is conflating the two and again
misleading the American people as has so
often been done especially within the
last couple of years his argument this
simple-minded it's stupid I would say
it's it comes from a position of
privilege and probably wanted bigotry as
well oh it's passive he's a racist so if
you say that slavery reparations is
unworkable and that you know an
immigrant like an Asian immigrant
shouldn't pay slavery reparations to
perhaps Kamala Harris who does not have
ancestors who were slaves that that is
apparently racist now and Tom lemon
definitely definitely deserves
reparations because Don Lemon makes what
3 million dollars a year something like
that so clearly the poor white guy in
Appalachia should be paying reparations
to Don Lemon for the fact that 150 years
ago Don lemons great-great-great-great
great-grandfather might have been
enslaved by somebody who once knew the
great-great great-great great-great
grand uncle of the guy in Appalachia I
mean the reparations is unworkable
everybody knows it and everybody knows
that this is a talking point that is
specifically designed to generate
controversy not to help heal old wounds
nobody has yet come up with a workable
framework or an explanation of what this
would look like and asking those
questions is now considered racist why
because this is an error
the media wishes to draw now speaking of
narratives that the media wishes to draw
it is amazing how these values are
crammed down on the American citizenry
so there is a a teacher who was recently
who recently kicked a student out of
class for insisting that there were only
two genders really this is the thing
that happened so that the teacher was
talking specifically about biological
sex and the student said there are only
two sexes male and female
which is true there are intersex people
but there are only two actual sexes male
and female biologically speaking
intersex people exist but this does not
obliterate the categories of male and
female okay so the student says this and
the teacher immediately expels the kid
from class while acknowledging openly
that what he is saying is utterly a
scientific my opinion and that is an
opinion which is acceptable in the
school my feet yours which you've seen
that there's no such thing as there
anyone other than male or female
designed to be there are just two
genders depending on what I get I guess
then you are choosing to make an issue
of this because I said are you really
going to you that was your opportunity
to keep quiet
not in so you get to put your opinion
out in class and why no I am not my
minion house of states I'm not putting
my opinion I'm not putting my opinion
out I am stating what is National School
Authority policy okay and then the
student says it's not scientific
whatsoever and the teacher concludes not
every policy is scientific Marie oh this
is good well here's what happens when
policy is not based on science or
anything else by whether this happened I
believe in Scotland so this is not
happening in in the United States yet
okay so here is what you end up with you
end up with this bizarre argument that
sex does not exist and if sex does not
exist then no such thing exists as
straight or gay or sexual preference or
anything like that and this leads to the
inherent absurdity of the piece I'm
about to bring you from psychology today
Karen Blair writing professor Karen
Blair here ready for this because you're
gonna have to put on your confusing
you're confused hat on because this is
this is this is deeply confusing you'll
see why the article is called our trans
people excluded from the world of dating
new research explores the
which trans people are excluded from
dating so basically this professor and
colleagues published some findings to a
survey question of who would you date
the studies the findings were published
in the Journal of Social and personal
relationships according to the piece our
results indicated that eighty seven
point five percent of the participants
who are asked this very question only
checked off the cisgender options
meaning a person who believes that their
gender corresponds to their sex may your
female and you think you're a female
excluded transgender and non-binary
individuals from their hypothetical
dating pool this apparently is
responsible for the suffering of the
transgender community it is not in fact
that gender dysphoria is a mental
condition that leads to depression and
is heavily linked with it it must be
societal discrimination and cruelty and
what the article basically purports to
say is that you are in fact a sexist if
you will not date a transgender person
they say well only a very small minority
of cisgender heterosexual individuals
were willing to date trans person a much
greater percentage of individuals who
identified as bisexual or queer provided
inclusive responses now listen to this
take one reason for this may be that
individuals with queer or bisexual
sexual orientations are already looking
beyond gender in many ways when
selecting a person to date well I have
another alternative to this idiotic tank
here's the alternative if you're a
cisgender heterosexual if you're a man
who thinks you're man and you're
heterosexual you would like to have sex
with biological women and if you present
me with a biological man who says he is
a woman I will not be attracted to that
person because I am a heterosexual man
who's attracted to physical women to
actual biological women whereas if you
are bisexual you don't care do you
because you're attracted to both sexes
so it's not that cisgender heterosexual
individuals are bigots it's that they
are attracted to exactly the people they
say that are attracted to and that's not
bigotry that's called human evolution
and biology which has led to the pro
generation of the species but we're so
stupid now and we have reached a point
where if you are a man who is straight
and you say you will not date a
biological man who says he's a woman
then this makes you gay or bisexual
right because the biological man who
says he has a woman is actually a woman
according to the left so if Bob over
there the three hundred hairy got three
hundred pound
dude if that guy says he's actually
Cecile and you're like not you know not
interested why are you're gay man you're
gay if you're not into Bob you're gay
because Bob is actually Cecile even
though he's 300 pounds hairy and has a
penis you are an you are now you're gay
I'm sorry to tell you this if you don't
sleep with that physical dude you're a
gay man because he's actually a woman
this is what happens when you conflate
sender this is what happens when you
separate gender from sex and say they
are absolutely malleable sex is not
gender you can identify however you want
and then you merge them back in and you
say no sex is actually gender so this is
what happens when you say in be a
biological man who and your gender is a
woman but also trans women are real
women if by real you mean like
biological if by real you mean should be
treated like a woman in every aspect of
life then you are saying something so
radically incoherent that you end up
with the bizarre result that if you are
a homosexual man who will not sleep with
a woman who say she is a man this is
because you are gay what now this is
because you are straight actually so if
you so again to take the counter example
you're a gay man the only one has sex
with dudes and here's a chick and she
says hey I'm a man and she has all all
the lady parts and you're like well you
know not really into that because like
I'm into dudes and then and and she says
no no but I am a dude you know but you
don't get not like biological bigot
not only are you a bigot you are
straight secretly you're straight if you
don't want to have sex with a woman and
you're a man it's because you're
straight by this perverse logic we are
so disconnected from anything remotely
approaching reality at this point that
there is no way for us to even have
basic conversations if words just have
no meanings this is how you get to where
we are and it's absurd in the extreme
okay well we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content plenty more to talk
about Plus we'll be back here at
tomorrow as always i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Clavin show Alexandria
occasional cortex says arresting illegal
immigrants is like the Holocaust because
she's an ignoramus but there is someone
partying just like it's 1938 and guess
what it's not president the Donnell I'll
talk about it on the Andrew Clavin show
I'm Andrew Clavin